voit plus au poiré est ce parce qu'il ne
vous appelle plus parce qu'il ne vous
intéresse plus parce que vous êtes pour
occuper avec votre petit avec votre
métier
le tout mon capitaine à écouter jeu là
la vérité c'est que la première année
j'étais enceinte et la grossesse moi ça
m'a bien fait gonfler j'avais les pieds
comme ça la deuxième année je venais
d'accoucher d'un enfant malade et la
troisième année j'étais au canada voit
l'année prochaine majeau sais pas s'ils
m'appellent et puis s'il m'appelle pas
ben et après on est tellement nombreux
d'artistes que on peut pas non plus être
tout sauf la fille natacha quand ils
vont voir notre duo n'appelleront pas du
tout théo
oui j'ai une question on a lu dans la
presse que vous aviez refusé danse avec
les stars
ouais et j'ai une question du coût est
vous avez refusé par principe ou parce
que l'argent n'était pas assez important
non j'ai refusé parce que il ya un truc
en fait cette émission il faut le dire
danse avec les stars en france à travers
le monde elle est reconnue comme étant
la meilleure version de toul et danse
avec les stars
alors ma critique elle est très objectif
c'est que moi j'aime pas les parties
dans une émission où on est assis dans
un canapé il faut qu'on se confier le
journaliste fait vous étiez triste non
j'étais en forme
c'est dur quand même non ça allait vous
avez eu un peu de mal tout à fait il ya
un moment donné tu as envie de dire tu
veux me faire dire quoi et j'aime pas ce
genre de travail là si j'ai un truc à
dire je le dis si j'ai rien à dire je le
dis pas et ils vous avez bien fait de
refuser parce que les cliniques étiez
trop connu pour lancer avec les flammes
non mais c'est une très belle émission
que je respecte vraiment beaucoup
simplement plutôt que de mal le faire je
préfère pas le faire et même si comme
avec pamela anderson vous propose quatre
cent mille euros
sinon on va réfléchir
l'agent réfléchit pas la même en
réfléchi et je danse avec pamela où la
place de caméras à la place de pamela
leur sein mais là oui sincèrement on
réfléchit mais là cette année j'ai une
belle année et je fais partie de ces
gens qui ont le luxe dans la vie de ne
pas toujours devoir faire des choix
économiques et c'est pas et il faut le
dire parce que tous les artistes n'ont
pas ce luxe là tout le temps ça veut pas
dire que j'ai des millions et des
millions ça veut juste dire que je fais
partie des gens qui ont la chance de
juniors des projets qu'ils aiment
voilà et de continuer à vivre de mon
métier
et si vous voulez priez pour moi fait en
sorte que je puisse continuer à avoir
cette libre